foreign
and welcome to today's webinar biopharma
101 analysis of mrna-based Therapeutics
I am Kaylee Bach of labyrinths and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by psyx to learn more visit cyx.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers
Stephen calciano Market development
manager biopharma Ms at psyx
Paula orins Market development manager
biopharma CE at psyx
Nathan Condor workflow specialist
nucleic acid therapies at saitiva and
Dave sokolowski Global workflow manager
at saitiva
Stephen Paula Nathan and Dave you may
now begin your presentation
hello everyone and welcome to biopharma
101 analysis of mrna-based Therapeutics
my name is Steven and I'm a market
development manager for
biopharmaceuticals at psyx I'm joined by
my colleagues Paula and Nathan and we're
here to discuss mRNA workflows with you
today
so first let's start with an
introduction on this topic of mRNA
delivered by Nathan and then Paula and I
will take a deep dive into recent
advances in analytical capabilities to
support these next generation modalities
hello this is Nathan Condor nucleic acid
Therapeutics workflow specialist for
sativa and today I'd like to give you an
overview around mRNA workflows
so here's an overview in general of the
MRNA production workflow for
manufacturing
starting with plasmid production going
into the second section mRNA
Manufacturing and then going into
encapsulation and filling with lnps as
the final drug product
but for this section
we're going to focus on plasmids plasmid
production is utilized for several
different biomolecular applications
including the production of mRNA
so for those that don't know plasmids
were discovered in the mid-1900s they've
been around for a while in
biotherapeutic applications
and other biological research
applications they're small pieces of
double-stranded circular DNA that exist
in many prokaryotic and a few eukaryotic
cells they replicate independently from
the bacterial DNA and are inherited by
the progeny bacterium
through genetic engineering you're able
to insert a gene or sequence of Interest
into a plasmid and then have the
bacteria start to produce this modified
plasma typically called a vector
biologically in cell reactors
that material the plasma and Vector
materials and separated from the cells
bacterial cells and purified to produce
up to GMP grade material for therapeutic
applications
in the case of mRNA the plasmid will be
linearized then to act as a template for
the MRNA production enzymatically
through in vitro transcription or ivt
uh but plasmids may also be used to
secrete proteins from the cells the
proteins will then be purified later as
a therapeutic agent as in maps or they
may be used as a direct DNA vaccine in
some cases or viral Vector it's for gene
therapy
some of the appeal around mRNA is that
there's a lower risk of cell-related
impurities
um and the titers have been higher than
some traditional biomolecules like Maps
this means that you can get a lot more
active material out of a certain
comparable volume and you don't have to
have these huge 2 000 liter
bioreactors to produce enough material
for a disease population size
or vaccine population size in some cases
now let's take a look at a few scenarios
for scale up to manufacturing due to the
urgency of the pandemic many of these
processes were scaled up quickly using
equipment that was useful for production
however oftentimes the equipment wasn't
designed with with mRNA in mind
and with the higher titers of material
produced you will be able to use
relatively small volume reactors you can
deal with low you know they were dealing
with low efficiency still capturing
enough material to deliver a large
number of doses
so
in the design uh you know you definitely
don't want to end up with a factory with
this these huge volume capability when
you when you're looking at you know rare
disease or more of a small small
personalized space
because you can produce a relatively
high amount of material with um with a
small volume
So currently there is no definitive
platform for lmrna development and
production the eurodops can vary widely
they can be some Homebrew methods that
don't scale well but in general you can
group them into these following
subgroups
sativa and Paul have a good presence
with bioreactors filtration and
purification products in these you know
DNA template and RNA product production
and in in LMP
further polishing
and then Precision Nano contributes a
considerable amount of expertise around
the lmps themselves and lipids in
general
um and then bannerx fills fills a need
here for filling
um and other opcos like psyx for
analytics
um analytics is something to be
considered right away as many steps
don't have in process monitoring or
analytics currently with these some of
these Homebrew methods so material can
sometimes be over consumed allocating to
to many different steps in purification
and then analysis and filtration and
Analysis and so on
thank you Nathan for the great
introduction and for the state of the
industry of mRNA production
as you mentioned analytics is something
to be considered early on in the MRNA
development process so today we'll be
providing an overview of five core
workflows that can help you better
characterize and monitor your mrna-based
products
we will cover plasmid analysis RNA
sequencing and shape modeling
mRNA Purity and integrity analysis
identification of the five Prime end
structure and lipid nanoparticle
impurity assessments
plasmids which are double-stranded DNA
are used throughout the development of
Next Generation biopharmaceuticals
analysis of double-stranded DNA is an
integral part of manufacturing nucleic
acids as Therapeutics for Gene and cell
therapy as well as for DNA vaccines
it's important to ensure their quality
as plasmid production can generate
topological variants including
supercoiled open circular and linear
isoforms of varying length
the Food and Drug Administration
guidelines recommend manufacturers to
include the gene map with relevant
restriction sites for gene therapy
Vector constructs and Vector diagrams
identifying the gene insert regulatory
regions and pertinent restrictions under
nuclease sites when submitting
applications for investigational new
drugs
this requires an accurate sizing
workflow and capillary gel
electrophoresis with laser-induced
fluorescence detection provides an easy
workflow for both topoisoform analysis
and accurate sizing with high
sensitivity
plasmid isoform testing can help ensure
product quality throughout all stages of
development
monitoring plasma isoform distribution
during production can help you optimize
each of the Via process unit operations
efficiently
traditionally this assay was run on
agarose gel electrophoresis and the
image on the right shows an example
analytical result
Lane 1 on the left shows a molecular
weight standard and the lane on the
right represents the supercoiled or
covalently closed circular DNA linear
DNA open circular DNA and a multimer
from bottom to top
the quantitative performance and
sensitivity of this assay however can be
improved through capillary
electrophoresis technology
capillary gel electrophoresis is a
highest sensitivity plasmid DNA sizing
workflow
here we show the confirmation of
different isoforms with control
standards
starting with the lowest Trace in purple
we see a 5 kilobase plasmid preparation
sample
above it in blue is a linear plasmid DNA
control standard and pink is an open
circular or nict control standard and in
green is a combination of the plasmid
prep with both control standards
we can see that the plasma prep contains
a high proportion of supercoil DNA but
there are some impurities including a
significant amount of open circular DNA
here we can demonstrate the workflow
sensitivity by analyzing a
double-stranded DNA test mix
the graph on top shows the analysis of
this text mix with a starting
concentration of 404 nanograms per
milliliter down to a limit of detection
at 0.79 nanograms per milliliter by
capillary gel electrophoresis
the bottom graph shows a sample
containing the sample DNA test mix but
also includes related product fragments
this method provides high resolution
between these complex plasmid DNA
samples
in general CE methods are highly
repeatable and this capillary gel
electrophoresis workflow for plasma
analysis is a good example of that
data from eight injections of the one
kilobase test ladder at 20 nanograms per
milliliter is shown on the graph
the percent RSD of the 1636 base pair
fragment was 0.43 for migration time and
2.19 for corrected Peak area across the
eight samples
analysis of restriction fragments can
help further characterize plasmids to
map genes inserts and Regulatory regions
this graph shows analysis of a sample
containing restriction fragments of a
bacteriophage DNA a DNA standard letter
and a linear plasmid DNA
this method offers high resolution
between closely utilized DNA and can be
used for accurate size determination of
unknown fragments
now moving on to our second analytical
workflow RNA secondary structure
modeling studies offer on analytical
solution to accelerate the
commercialization of rna-based products
capillary electrophoresis technology
enables an automated High throughput
approach to map RNA molecules and
understand their secondary structure and
provide product specific confirmation
through base identification
the workflow we'll discuss in this
section is RNA shape analysis by
capillary electrophoresis
let's take a look at some of the
complexity we can be dealing with when
analyzing RNA here is a view of an
example RNA ty1 retrotransposon
you can see that just having sequence
information of this molecule is only
telling part of the story
there are complex structural elements
throughout the RNA including internal
loops hairpins multi-branch loops bulges
and in this case even dimerization as
seen through the Symmetry in the middle
of the molecule
RNA chemical probing using the shape
reaction depends on RNA 2 Prime o adduct
formation following RNA isolation by
highly electrophilic reagents such as
nmia
unconstrained mRNA contains sites that
are readily accessible for this reaction
the degree of RNA isolation over the RNA
transcript is critical for premature
reverse transcription and C DNA
enrichment
using cdna fragment analysis by
capillary electrophoresis and
computational software the RNA shape
reaction can be used to perform RNA
secondary structural modeling
the overall RNA shape workflow is
depicted in this diagram
starting with the RNA we want to analyze
we split the sample into a control
reaction and a shape reaction sample
the control reaction provides us with
the Baseline RNA structure to compare to
the nmia reactant samples
reverse transcription using IDT Freedom
dies is then carried out in the presence
of a dntp mix
the resulting cdna fragments and
sequence letters are then analyzed on
the psyx gexp genetic analyzer
we then perform data interpretation to
assign nucleotide reactivity values that
are found by comparing the shape reacted
samples with the control samples
these reactivity values are then used
with structural modeling software to
enhance structural modeling accuracy
accuracy
the example diagram on the right shows
how structural modeling with shape can
offer insights into RNA secondary
structure that could be missed when
doing in Silicon modeling alone
here is a summary of the sample
preparation that's required for shape
analysis
on day one
we relax the RNA structure and then
perform the RNA isolation reaction with
the nmia reagent to yield the RNA to
Prime oatic formations at flexible RNA
regions
then we'd perform RNA precipitation
on day two we synthesize the
complementary DNA fragments with reverse
transcription of both the positive
reaction and our negative reaction
step two combines both the positive and
negative reaction samples and creates
the mixture
on day three we add in the DNA ladder
and combine all of these together and
run shape analysis using the gexp
fragment analysis system the nucleic
acid fragments are resolved one base at
a time and the fluorescence intensity at
each of the complementary DNA fragments
will indicate which bases are at the
truncated region
here's an example of HP rt1 RNA shape
reaction profiling by capillary gel
electrophoresis
four primer sets were designed to cover
the 1 395 nucleotide HP rt1 transcript
positive reactions indicates hprt1
transcripts is treated with the nmia
reagent
here the blue signal indicates a
positive reaction and a green signal is
a control reaction
the black and red traces are used as DNA
sequencing ladders
once Kepler electrophoresis analysis is
completed shapefinder software is then
used to process the data
the top section shows the normalized
positive reaction in blue over the
control reaction in green
the gap or difference between the blue
and green Trace suggests the degree of
RNA to Prime oatic formation which can
be interpreted as the flexibility of a
respective nucleotide
the bottom section shows DNA sequencing
for thymine in black and or adenine in
red
the lines in the diagram indicate the
identity of each Peak and their
alignment to the hprt1 reference
sequence
the figure on the left is a secondary
structural model using the data
processing tool RNA Thor you can see an
example of the gexp data that was
analyzed for the shapefinder That Was
Then uploaded to RNA Thor
RNA Thor results include nucleotide
sequence identity and a calculated shape
reactivity value
these shape reactivity values can be
used to optimize in Silicon structural
modeling of RNA with real-world data
points
here is how all of the various workflow
components fit together
first you generate shape fragments and
separate them by capillary
electrophoresis
then you generate nucleotide reactivity
values with shapefinder that can then be
used to feed structural modeling tools
and improve in silico predictive
modeling with real world data
our third and final CE base workflow is
used to determine mRNA Purity and
perform a size estimation
when optimizing the production of mRNA
it's important to assess the quality of
the final product including its
integrity and Purity to ensure product
efficacy
an effective mRNA sizing workflow can
help resolve closely related fragments
that differ by as little as a few bases
from complex formulations including mRNA
encapsulated in lipid nanoparticles
crispr Gene editing systems and viral
Vector genomes
the key workflow we will discuss in this
section is capillary gel electrophoresis
with laser-induced fluorescence
here we are showing the workflow for
analysis of messenger RNA lipid
nanoparticles from left to right we can
see sample preparation of messenger RNA
lipid nanoparticles were treated to
release the MRNA for capillary
electrophoresis analysis
in this example we took a collection of
samples from different storage
conditions for our product stability
assessment
the control sample preparation was
diluted in water and heated at 70
degrees C for 5 minutes
the experimental buffer was a 0.3 Triton
X100 buffer in water and heat for 70
degrees C for five minutes to release
mRNA from lipid nanoparticles
our studies showed that this
experimental buffer did a much better
job at extracting RNA from lipid
nanoparticles than by simply using water
and Heat
once the MRNA was treated with the
Triton X100 the samples were loaded into
a CE system and analyzed with a high
throughput kit for analysis
on the right we can see an example of
the analytical results we can expect
from this workflow which includes a main
Peak a minor Peak to the left and a very
low level of impurities
in the next few slides we will show how
we can analyze various mRNA lipid
nanoparticle product storage conditions
with this method to determine optimal
conditions which can preserve mRNA
integrity
here we can see a profile of in vitro
transcribed RNA prior to mRNA LNP
formulation
this data will serve as the Baseline
profile that we can use for stability
and Purity profiling over different
product storage conditions
the green Trace represents a blank
sample
or our background signal
the red Trace represents the ivt reacted
mRNA or in vitro transcribed reacted
mRNA
the main product migrated at 17 minutes
corresponding to an expected size of 1.8
kilobases
we will show how the capillary
electrophoresis platform can perform
this accurate seismic estimation in a
few slides
we also see RNA degradation products
either by natural degradation or
incomplete in vitro transcription
labeled as impurities under the black
bracket
we can also see a minor product right
before the main Peak also notably there
are no high molecular weight impurities
observed in this control sample
here we can see an overview of the
capabilities of this method for
characterization of the starting
material
here are three electropherograms showing
RNA profiling if of three sequential
injections
we can see the summary data in the table
on the right across these three
injections
the main product corrected Peak area
percentage was 89.28 with a percent CV
of under 2 percent
the minor product corrected Peak area
percentage was 5.61 with a percent CV of
less than three percent
the column to the right shows the
calculated size of the main products
with an average size of 1.849 kilobases
with a percent CB of less than two
percent
to determine the size of the RNA we can
utilize an RNA ladder once the RNA
letter is resolved in this case over the
range of 50 to 9000 bases the capillary
electrophoresis software can then be
used to determine size of unknown
fragments within this range
this slide shows the analysis of both in
vitro transcribed RNA and RNA extracted
from lipid nanoparticles by capillary
electrophoresis with and without
oxidation
this graph overlays five
electropherograms
the wrench Ray shows the profile of free
mRNA after in vitro transcription which
is also our Baseline indicator for the
expected level of impurities and high
molecular weight products
the green Trace represents mRNA
lipidinal particles after synthesis
pink and blue traces show ivt reacted
mRNA and RNA extraction from lnps
subject to oxidative stress
the aqua traces are control
we can see in the green Trace that the
extracted RNA from the lipid
nanoparticles resulted in a main product
that has the same migration time as the
Baseline main product in our red Trace
this tells us that the main product is
still found in the MRNA lipid
nanoparticles
we do however see in the green Trace
that we can detect the high molecular
wave product
you can also see the free mRNA in the
pink Trace which was exposed to
oxidative conditions is very similar to
the aquatrace which shows that the
oxidative conditions degraded a majority
of the MRNA
we can also see the blue Trace shows a
major decrease in the main product which
indicates that the lipid nanoparticle
provides some protective effects for
mRNA
this analysis can prove useful for
developers looking to understand how
their mRNA may be impacted by adverse
storage conditions
this workflow can be used to determine
the concentration of mRNA extracted from
lip and nanoparticles
the x-axis on this chart illustrates the
MRNA concentration and the y-axis
indicates the corrected Peak area as
determined by capillary electrophoresis
using capillary gel electrophoresis with
laser-induced fluorescence was analyzed
with triplicate injection
we are able to determine RNA
concentration over three orders of
magnitude with a lower limit of
detection of 97.9 nanograms per ML and a
limit of quantitation at 390.6 nanograms
per ml
here is an overview of the workflow for
automatic RNA size estimation
panels a b and c show three sequential
injections of RNA extracted from lip and
nanoparticles for a sample that was
stored for 92 days at negative 20
degrees Celsius
we can see the profile of the RNA ladder
which is in red and the MRNA extracted
from the lip nanoparticle which is in
green it was consistent across three
injections
the main product is labeled one the
minor product Label 2 and the higher
molecular weight product labeled 3.
using data processing features in the
capillary electrophoresis software we
can see the main product has an average
size of 1.937 kilobases with a present
CV below 2 percent
the minor product has an average size of
1.841 kilobases with a percent CV less
than two percent as well and a high
molecular weight product average size of
2.407 kilobases with a percent CV of
less than four percent
Kepler electrophoresis is a great
technology that can be applied to allies
mRNA in many different ways to support
product development and quality control
now I'd like to hand it off to Paula to
take us through some Mass Spec based
characterization workflows for mRNA and
lnps
thanks for the introduction and the
handoff Stephen so I am going to cover
our final two workflows beginning with
the identification of the five Prime cap
structure of in vitro transcribed mRNA
when mRNA is trans transcribed in vitro
or ivt the five Prime cap is necessary
to maintain the biological function of
the MRNA this is typically done
enzymatically in three reactions and
results in a single nucleotide addition
at the five Prime end depicted here in
this nice animation
however this three-step process also
results in an uncapped mRNA as well as
various intermediates these
intermediates can be observed throughout
the process the process which starts as
an uncapped mRNA with two phosphate
groups of the five Prime end then the
first enzymatic reaction forms what is
called a gcap g based on the enzyme the
second reaction forms cap zero and then
the final reaction finally forms the
five Prime cap of interest and I'll kind
of just give you a second to observe
these reactions and mechanisms without
trying to explain it myself
as a control in this experiment an
uncapped sample was prepared and
separated in parallel with the cap
sample so here on the left side is the
full scan Toff Ms data for uncapped in
blue and capped mRNA in Black the charge
states of the main species in each
sample are indicated by the red bars or
also hyper masses and then on the right
hand side
is a zoom in of the most abundant charge
state which is z minus 11 and it's
depicted as raw data as well as the
reconstructed data which exhibits great
comparability uh between the two so you
can see the diphosphate denoted here
with two P's this peak right here
containing version or the this version
contains the most abundant as the
uncapped sample whereas for the capped
mRNA cap one is actually the most
abundant Peak and that is exactly as you
would hope it would be
we can also look at the xic or extracted
iron chromatograms of the most abundant
charge State for the pp uncap which is
that double phosphate and the cap one of
the uncapped and capped mRNA
respectively under the green umbrella
the Reconstruction of the raw data
allowed identification of different
capped and uncapped species as well as
their metal adducts now these addicts
sodium potassium and iron were observed
for mRNA carrying two or three terminal
phosphates due to the strong chelation
effect of diphosphate and the metal ions
in solution without EDTA now all species
are showing excellent resolution for raw
and reconstructed data and there's great
comparability again between the
reconstructed and the raw data
this table lists all the species we were
able to identify as expected we
identified the MRNA intermediates from
the three-step enzymatic process of
adding the five Prime cap as well as
different levels of phosphorylation and
those previously mentioned metal adducts
we are also identified in both capped
and uncapped species
now to assess to assess capping
efficiency the intact quantification
workflow in psyx OS was used and in
brief raw Toff Ms Spectra was
reconstructed and mass Peaks were
integrated using the analytics module
now I customized formula was used to
calculate Peak area ratios of each
species against the total sum then all
addicts were taken into account for the
highest accuracy and through this we
were able to determine that the capping
efficiency was 43.2 percent so a little
less than 50 but not so bad I guess
with this last topic we're nearing the
home stretch and I might be a bit biased
but I think we definitely saved the best
for last no offense
in this workflow we're covering
oxidative impurities from ionizable
lipids used in lipid nanoparticle
formulations Madness is an extremely
important topic because it was recently
published that certain oxidations of
ionizable lipids lead to covalent
modifications of ribonucleotides which
results in a loss of mRNA potency
MC3 for short is an ionizable lipid used
in LNP formulations like other ionized
the lipids its structure contains a
tertiaryamine which is on a three carbon
head group that is bonded via an ester
linkage to two separate but identical
alkyl chains containing double bonds at
both C6 and C9 now on the bottom is a
preview of the information you can
gather when using electron activated
dissociation this is the main peak of
the ionizable lipid and if I can call
your attention to the percent intensity
on the left hand side
the main Peak we see is a hundred
percent but it's when you start to zoom
in on the Baseline to see what else is
present that these impurities in super
low abundance become clear like these
two impurities which I'll identify
momentarily
less than 0.2 percent of the main Peak
these Peaks have different retention
times but the same precursor of 659 and
the isotopic distribution but I'll tell
you the increase of 16 AMU compared to
the main Peak indicate that these are
isomers containing an oxygen atom so to
differentiate we'll have to do msms and
we'll get to that in a moment but next
is the impurity on the back end at less
than two percent and the sensitivity of
this assay can be attributed to the
xenotrap increasing the sensitivity of
the system ultimately ensuring that all
of the sample you're introducing to the
source is getting to the detector at the
top of the top
this is the Toff Ms of that main MC3
Peak that we just saw the observed M
over Z is for the singly charged MC3
with a single PPM and we'll fragment
this peak with a traditional technique
called CID as well as alternative
fragmentation the aforementioned EAD or
electron activated dissociation
from CID this inset here shows that it's
not a very rich Spectra if you can see
it that there's any Spectra at all
however if we look at the same msms data
but this time using EAD to fragment then
there is a wealth of information that we
can gather with over 100 Peaks that can
be assigned to structures from in silico
derived fragments now more specifically
some of these Peaks like 531 545 571
they can all be used to confirm
localization of the double bonds at C6
or c31 C9 c28 and they'll both produce
the 132 Peak that indicates
dimethylaminobutanoate head group the
one I showed you earlier only EAD
produces the complementary fragment ions
at 511 which represents the two
identical alkyl chains
foreign
Purity is oxidation specifically it's
important to be able to localize the
oxidation because of the study I
mentioned earlier which reported that n
oxidations of ionized lipids can lead to
the loss of mRNA potency so we have to
be able to understand the oxidation to
identify potential side effects so
thankfully with electron activated
dissociation we can do just that so the
first impurity we're going to look at is
the alkyl chain oxidation which would
look a little something like this this
double bond is reduced to the alkyl
group or the double bond is reduced and
the alkyl group becomes oxidized
foreign
let's look at the msms Spectra so at
first glance the 132 is present and
that's the one I said is indicative of
the head group suggesting the oxidation
occurred on one of the alkyl chains but
where of those two locations that it
could be located is what we have to find
out so with EAD we're able to generate a
few more diagnostic fragments that will
help us localize the oxidation between
C5 or 32 C6 31 so the epoxide proposed
here is because of the lack of
diagnostic fragment ions at 61 and 511
which would indicate oxidation of the
head group but with the uh with the
oxidation occurring on the second alkyl
chain then you can see we are
identifying these 558 574 and 587 ions
here
let's take a look at what we'd see in
that instance so if the head group or
the tertiary mean was oxidized instead
of the alkyl chain
then we would observe this 61 148 and
511.5 and you'll remember on the last
slide at the bottom it said no 148.
another reason it's indicative that we
were seeing the alkyl chain oxidation
previously but this is the impurity that
we need to be wary of When developing
our LNP formulations
if we go back to our msms data a unique
Ion at 61 indicated that the oxidation
occurs on the head group how are we
certain that the oxidation doesn't occur
in both places uh you'll recall I said a
mass shift of 16 AMU so that's only one
oxygen incorporation but to confirm it
even further these diagnostic fragments
here 148 511 show that the alkyl chains
are untouched so the oxidation could
only be incorporated with the
dimethylamino group itself
the last of the three impurities
identified was the reduction of the
double bond however there are four of
them present on two different alkyl
chains so we need to localize exactly
where the double bond has been reduced
so we'll look at the possible fragments
for an unmodified MC3 which I've
highlighted here in red as well as a or
compare them to what it would look like
for a double bond modification after the
reduction
this is an overlay of EAD msms Spectra
of the main Peak MC3 in red and the
impurity Peak that eluded at 16.9
minutes
that impurity Peak showed a gain of
about 2 AMU compared to the main peak of
MC3 so fragmenting that impurity
resulted in an increase of about two AMU
compared to that of the main peak of MC3
common fragment ions at 531
545.4 are observed in both species and
are indicative of the C9 c828 double
bond and unique ion pairs 558.5 559.5 as
well as 572.5
573.5 indicate the location of one
double bond reduction at the C6 c31
taken together this data demonstrates
that the impurity was a result of a
single double bond reduction by the gain
of two protons specifically at the C6
c31 location
and I'll give you a second to
kind of take all of this in
for the sake of time I've chosen not to
go through each of the impurities
identified in this workflow but I wanted
to provide you with a brief summary of
the ones that we did Cover and the ones
that we didn't cover
but eag was used to characterize the
structures of the ionizable lipid MC3
and low-level related impurities and it
was achieved in a single injection lcms
Ms experiment that used a 20-minute
gradient
and compared to other fragmentation
techniques this product ion data is
extremely comprehensive and provides an
in-depth structural detail throughout
the lipid species analyzed MC3 oxidative
impurities and determine specific sites
of oxygen incorporation and the data was
also used to localize specific sites of
double bonds and related saturation
impurities
it has also been used or EAD I will say
has also been used to provide complete
structural details of glycerol
phospholipids and other ionizable lipids
not just MC3 the technique can be used
to provide rapid sensitive and very
detailed structural analysis of lipids
within LNP formulations for liability
studies and for raw materials testing
overall I would say the information
provided by EAD can enhance product
quality and safety of LMP formulated
products as well as guiding synthesis
and development of Novel ionized lipids
that have higher quality stability and
maybe therapeutic efficacy to further
unlock the real potential of rna-based
Therapeutics and vaccines
I would like to take kind of one final
minute to tell you about our psych's now
Learning Hub where there is a lot of
very educational content available just
at your fingertips whether you've got uh
or you whether you've just started in a
new lab or you've got new scientists
starting in your lab and you're just
looking for some great information that
will get them started on capillary
electrophoresis mass spectrometry or how
to use either and more please feel free
to stop by our psyx now Learning Hub
on behalf of Stephen and myself I want
to thank our saitiva speaker for joining
us today and providing us with some of
this great educational content
um and we thank all of you for taking
the time to join us today it's been a
lot of fun getting to learn mRNA and
lipid nanoparticles along with all of
you
thank you Stephen Paula Nathan and Dave
for your informative presentation we
will now start the live q a portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
all right so let's get started
our first question here asks what
software do you need to process the
5-inch cap data on MS
thanks Kaylee so the simple answer is
psyx OS this software has an intact
Quant add-in that is for automated
deconvolution of a charge date series
and it was obviously originally
developed for intact protein Quant and
flexible mam but it works just as well
for oligos you can set up the intact
Quant to focus on the specific capping
intermediates to provide reconstructed
Peak areas of each and then set up a
simple custom calculation to calculate
the percent yield of the final cap
product so it is a bit of an automated
software solution and then Additionally
you can also use molecule profiler to
build custom five Prime modifications of
different Cappy intermediates and this
will help identify any related
impurities so those Peaks but in short
psyx OS can be used for both the
acquisition and automated calculation of
the percent yield
great thank you Paula next question will
this slide deck be made available to
participants
I can take that one uh so this is Steven
I believe we'll have access to the
on-demand version of this session but
feel free to contact uh myself or Paula
if you'd like to get access to this to
the slide so our contact information
should be available and don't hesitate
to follow up
great thanks and I'll add to that
Stephen this presentation will be
available for on-demand viewing after
the session
and we'll continue with the questions
here this next one asks can the plasmid
DNA analysis workflow be applied to
in-process samples
and I'll take that one again
um so that's it's really a great
question
um because typically the biopharma
industry tends to try to apply capillary
electrophoresis for a final plasma drug
product testing and not necessarily for
in-process testing or monitoring
for in-process analysis you know
concentration is typically done by UV
Vis and product quality analysis may be
done by hplc with something like ion
exchange chromatography
there are some drawbacks to that method
though specifically around assay
sensitivity and its comparability to the
gold standard assay which is gel
electrophoresis so it could be manual
manual gel electrophoresis for top
isoform analysis
um that being said we have had success
with this workflow for in-process
plasmid Topo isoform analysis and that's
through the dilution of uh these crude
samples really to dilute out the
interferences uh presence uh in in these
crude samples and we can do that because
the assay by cge or capillary gel
electrophoresis really is sensitive
enough to still detect these minor
isoforms uh while being quantitative so
we do eliminate also the need for UV Vis
so it can be a very nice in process
characterization solution
great
well we will go ahead and wrap up there
I want to thank you again Stephen Paula
Nathan and Dave for your time today and
your important research we would also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
psyx for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab Roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone goodbye